it looks like the North Pole but believe
it or not this is the mighty Mississippi
River frozen over Minneapolis has been
in the deep freeze since the polar
vortex first struck in January now it's
back again Minnesotans are tough like
this woman out deicing her car in just a
shirt but it's fair to say even they
have now had enough this is a one of the
coldest years it's really cold yeah it
keeps getting colder keeps getting
colder we just had 30 35 weather but
drop right back down is it gonna carry
on like this do you think yeah well into
March I'm sure it's the coldest is the
most snow we ever had in years since I
was a kid yeah what's it like living
here I like living here I like the
summers but I hate the winners it's so
cold you wonder if the Midwest can ever
be roused from this winter the coldest
in decades it's minus 15 degrees
centigrade here at the moment but with
the wind chill over the next couple of
days that's likely to go down to minus
25 now they're used to the snow and the
cold here in Minnesota but they haven't
seen a winter like this since 1981 what
makes it particularly hard to endure is
so far there is no end in sight any Thor
seems to bring its own problems they
call this an ice jam when a frozen river
warms just enough to start breaking up
in Illinois here destroying what's in
its way those such problems in Minnesota
where they've woken to sub-zero
temperatures on 49 days that allows us
flood of arctic air the literally work
its way north to south west to east
someone has to take the blame imagine
being the weatherman in a winter like
this epic people hate me right now you
know you go into a coffee shop and they
give you a sideways glance and usually
people like hey how's it going hey
what's going on now it's a oh yeah any
hits it's a tough place to be they're
still finding a way to joke about it
here just but patience is wearing thin
despite the clear skies weather experts
there's no sign yet of this polar winter
coming to an end Dominic Waghorn Sky
News Minneapolis